la source ces belles paroles il est
temps de tourner à cannes pour retrouver
claude sion avec de très beaux invité
claude voilà dans quelques instants
j'aurai le privilège de rejoindre à la
table gérard oury entouré de michèle
morgan danièle thompson christopher
thompson et jean paul belmondo hommage à
gérard oury du festival de cannes ce
soir
auparavant deux instants importante de
la compétition cannoise une compétition
qui est souvent gras sérieuse d'un
quelques mois difficiles à regarder
on a notamment vu le film français de
cédric kahn roberto succo l'histoire de
ce gangster de ce malfaiteur qui a une
cavale meurtrière sanglante à la fin des
années 80 c'est vrai que cannes a
proposé ce roberto succo qui a beaucoup
intéressé ce matin la compétition
cannoise reportage de marie jo juin
patrick voit un inconnu de 26 ans pour
intervenir au vert tout sourit le tueur
en série tallien des années 80 repéré
dans la rue stefano cassetti a été
choisi pour donner plus d'intensité au
personnage je pense que les gens
pourront manger avec les femmes de la
maison je m'appelle paul ma femme aussi
de leur histoire et ses brimades et non
conseillé d'être commentée sur ça
c'était important de réfléchir
tout pour moi dans ma vie roberto zucco
sanguinaire imprévisible ennemi public
numéro un amoureux d'une lycéenne qu'il
épargnera même si tu me l'as des raisons
qui sont les coupables de quelques
années que c'était important pour moi
trouver la bonne distance
c'est à dire d'être avec roberto succo
et de le suivre à la trace comme ça dans
ses actions dans les choses un peu
extrême
et puis et puis aussi toujours de donner
une référence de réalisme et de montrer
ce qu'il a réellement fait pour rappeler
aux spectateurs qu'on est face à des
faits réels et de ne pas
qui est principe d'identification aux
personnages fini les brutes et chacun
france qu'il veut ou pas un film à
double détente romanesque mais aussi
documentaire et surtout la performance
étonnante données connues au regard
magnétique mazen aux passagers la bulle
est venu à dire aussi la joie d'y
impressionnant également le film du
réalisateur autrichien michael haneke la
pianiste easter d'une musicienne d'une
névrose terrible avec une performance
tout à fait étonnant d'isabelle huppert
parce qu'à deschamps et jean moulin nous
parle de cette performance des habits du
père dans ce film la pianiste
c'est une douloureuse musique des
sentiments que je vous avais lu père
professeur au conservatoire son
personnage eric a sacrifié sa vie pour
réussir sa carrière pendant 12 heures
elle va nous offrir le visage de la
détresse pur celui d'une femme qui
s'interdit des mais revenez au début
c'est quelqu'un qui est instinctivement
veut aussi faire voler en éclats les
schémas habituels de la domination
masculine sur les femmes et c'est
quelqu'un qui entretient une confusion
évidemment avec tout ça et qui d'emblée
pense que le sentiment amoureux va la
rendre dépendantes va de fer va faire
d'elle une victime eva la blesser
mortellement
je n'ai pas de sentiments malterre vous
feriez vous mettre ça dans la tête et
même si j'en ai à jour et ne
triompheront j'amène mon intelligence il
est difficile de traduire par quelques
secondes d'extrait la violence du film
soit pas s'il provoque ce n'est pas pour
ces images là mais pour d'autres michael
haneke film au scalpel les errances
d'une femme qui se réfugient la nuit
dans les rapports sadomasochistes
j'aurais pu avoir peur de faire le film
passe par là je l'aurais pas fait si
vraiment la peur avait été à surmontable
j'en ai pas eu peur je n'ai pas eu peur
parce que le cinéma étant avant tout
affaire de croyance
j'avais décidé d'y croire et le prr ans
michael haneke et je pensais pas que il
m'amènerait à la destruction
loin de là le réalisateur autrichien a
offert à isabelle huppert est l'un des
plus grands rôles de sa carrière
un rôle qui pourrait bien lui valoir 23
ans après violette nozière un nouveau
prix d'interprétation à cannes
voilà on y est pas encore ce sera
dimanche prochain pour l'instant ce soir
le moment d'émotion moment de vrai
bonheur c'était de retrouver gérard oury
sur les marches du palais du festival
il était entouré bien sûr de sa famille
que vous allez voir autour de moi sur
cette place
il y avait aussi smaïn boujenah et
beaucoup d'acteurs qui ont eu le plaisir
de jouer avec gérard oury sous sa
direction
gérard oury bonsoir bonsoir merci
beaucoup mais merci peut-être
globalement nous avoir fait tant rire
alors il ya un peu un paradoxe c'est le
cas ne vous avez jamais célébré à ce
point là bon c'est vrai je n'ai jamais
eu de film sélectionné à cannes bon
voilà et bien vous voyez tout vient à
point qui sait pas quand vous prenez ça
comme une revanche pour magali voilà moi
non pas une revanche je dis tout point
tout arrive tout arrive au le jour où
les choses doivent arriver s'il ya de
choses pour moi qui compte plus que tout
au monde c'est l'amour et l'amitié et à
cette table j'ai l'amour et l'amitié
je vais quand même est-ce que vous avez
une recette maintenant à dire maintenant
vous avez fait tous ces films recettes
de manière dont vous avez pu faire
autant de succès en si peu de chine tout
comme ça aucune recette recettes sinon
le prémice mans intérieur ça veut dire
tout d'un coup de se dire c'est ça qu'il
faut que je fasse
c'est elle interprète qui me font il va
me rejeter oui j'avais accepté ce sont
dont c'est une conjonction de d'artistes
dont le maître d'oeuvre est le metteur
en scène mais s'il ya plein ya plein de
points d'apport d'auteur de techniciens
c'est pour ça que quand je vois quand je
vois un film réussi je me dis mais tant
de gens ont travaillé ce film est réussi
c'est magnifique
il va demeurer peut-être trouvera-t-il
dans les années qui viennent je le dis
toujours des nouveaux supports qui lui
permettront d'exister encore dans x
années d'être un témoignage de de
l'époque que nous vivons
alors je vais interroger votre petit
fils christopher thompson qu'est ce que
vous avez appris de votre grand père
vous qui êtes à l'orée d'une carrière
c'est difficile de dire c'est difficile
de quantifier ça mais il ya une il ya
une transmission mais il ya une
transmission qui comme dans toutes les
familles je crois mais quitte une
transmission qu'il qui est essentielle
et qui est importante et qui sur des
choses de moi je n'ai vu travailler je
début aimé travailler adoré ce un plus
plus que tout je crois et et
voilà oui si je peux dire un truc c'est
ce vraiment ce bonheur dans le travail
qui va tout ce que j'ai vu là vous êtes
d'une génération fait plutôt des films
graves des films durs déchu lourd on
envoie quelques années alors que vous
êtes dans une famille où alors dieu sait
si on aime rigoler quand même rires oui
non oui non mais il ya des gens il ya
déjà des gens de ma génération qui font
des films drôles heureusement et ça
c'est etc il y en aura toujours sous je
pense que si on est c'est vrai qu'on est
à cannes et à cannes en général on voit
des films plus sérieux que rabbi jacob
qui est en train d'être projeté en ce
moment mais bon ça c'est un petit peu la
loi du genre et et c'est comme ça mais
c'est vrai que ce soir ya cette
projection et le bonheur comme moi j'ai
senti dans la salle tout à l'heure avec
obligés du public quand le quand le
générique a démarré qui sont attendus
cette musique tout le monde connaît il
ya une vraie jouissant les gens qui
était le leur voire xx x
danièle thompson c'est un artisanat
familial le cinéma l'art d'écrire de
bien écrire et de serre et à divertir
je pense que c'est un mélange mais je
pense que je pense que c'est merveilleux
quand on peut se transmettre justement
d'amorcer son bonheur de travailler dans
l'antre estater parlait parce que de
voir ses parents
partir le matin au travail heureux
d'aller faire ce qu'il faut finalement
c'est un privilège extraordinaire et
puis de leur donner envie donc j'imagine
de faire la même chose c'est ce que j'ai
ressenti avec mon père et pourtant quand
on est quand on est enfin d'acteur on
connaît aussi les difficultés ce un
métier et curieuse d'un métier d'acteur
réellement il était drôle où il était
sévère avec vous oh mon dieu il était il
était vraiment un père c'est à dire que
j'ai toujours vu quelqu'un qui adorait
rire ça c'est certain il y avait de
l'humour il ya un tour dans la famille a
toujours été un ton d'humour qui était
le sien c'est une malle grand mère
sylvie mamet mais il y avait une sorte
de de l'emitt ont toujours des limites
qu'on donne aux enfants maintenant il y
avait une éducation il y avait une
notion de l'importance du travail de
gagner sa vie et de faire métier
d'apprendre des choses ça c'était tout à
coup un autre chose c'était très
strictes
michel mauran quoi n'avez vous jamais
fait de comédie vraiment un petit peu
folle nord comme j'ai un horrible il
vous a jamais proposé non mais j'ai
tourné avec gérard j'ai tourné plusieurs
fois j'ai tourné tout à fait à ses
débuts les mettre en scène un film à
sketch dans lequel il y avait ce sketch
je paie c'était à sketches dans matière
et je crois que c'est dans ce film à
sketches que gerra a fait tourner
de funès dans un petit rôle et c'est de
finir ce qui lui a dit mais pourquoi ne
fait-il pas des films comiques et voilà
moi j'étais dans le premier film qui
était un film dramatique et après gérard
à fait défini comique et je ne me vois
pas très bien présent
ça fritsch grandeur non
oui préféré faire avec non seulement
faire des films comiques avec das neves
avec de funès vous n'iriez de de gérard
oury tu sais effectivement comme une
expression utilisée un artisan du cinéma
quelqu'un qui peaufine beaucoup son
travail
c'est un anxieux c'est que c'est tout à
la fois dépend des moments
ça dépend des jours mais c'est vrai que
c'est à la fois un artisan il a beaucoup
d'humour et il a le don de l'observation
donc il il fait amène à un mélange
savant d'humour de précision et de
travail
quand jean paul belmondo vous êtes
passés de godard à uri de melville à
brooke est alors comment on s'y retrouve
notamment comme travail et gérard oury
qui vous propose quand même des choses
difficiles drôle où il faut avoir un
energy un tonus incroyable mais vous
savez d'abord je crois que c'est une
chance pour avoir joué éric godin avec
gérard oury mais pour vous dire la
vérité ou accra j'ai voulu être acteur
c'était le comique qui m'attirait
conservateur j'ai travaillé que des
rôles comiques tout le temps tout le
temps et si godard qui avec à bout de
souffle a entraîné dans un autre genre
de cinéma et de rôle mais mon départ moi
mon rêve c'était de jouer des
vaudevilles convoi le cépage est
formidable voilà quand j'ai rencontré
gérard
j'étais fou de joie de tourner avec lui
parce que c'est un cinéma que vous et
gérard que j'adorais et il m'a donné un
personnage formidable et la joie de
jouer aussi avec bourvil
ils pouvaient être plus girard je dois
dire il était acteur donc c'est les
acteurs ou bien les acteurs et comme
gérard et isla il faut diriger comment
ils vous laissé libre de faire
d'inventer des choses où il est fait
très directif nous obliger à notre avis
il ya une bonne chose déjà il vous met
dans des bonnes situations c'est la
meilleure direction d'acteur c'est de
mettre l'acteur dans une bonne situation
et avec un beau rôle ce qui m'avait
donné
évidemment il a il dirige très très bien
mais c'est pas c'est pas un dictateur je
travaille à l'installation nous donne
pas des grands coups d prompt dans le
ventre ou nous dirigent avec il faut se
faire léger sur le pur sang sur le
cheval lui donner une espèce de caresses
intimes imagine pas dictateur non c'est
pas ça il s'est juste dire c'est qu'il
faut je crois que oui ça passe très vite
dans un journal mais on voulait
absolument vous rendre hommage ce soir
je voudrais que vous me disiez ce que
vous avez envie de transmettre et
qu'elle serait par exemple la leçon vous
tirer de vos années cinéma travail
travail travail une bonne histoire plus
une bonne histoire plus une bonne
histoire ces gamins qui disait ça et
c'est la vérité c'est ce qu'il faut je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs sortes de
cinéma il ya plein de cinéastes dans le
monde qui font des choses différentes
mais en tout cas pour ce qui me concerne
si j'avais quelque chose
un conseil à donner aux jeunes c'est une
bonne histoire plus une bonne histoire
que c'est une bonne issue c'est pas moi
qui les ai inventées
merci beaucoup d'être venus autour de
cette table et puis l'hommage du
festival de cannes à gérard oury a été
saluée par énormément de gens ce soir
merci nous avons beaucoup fait rire
beaucoup divertir
voilà benoît pour ce pétition spéciale
en direct de cannes